foreign
quick update here guys all right
and this is this is sad this is sad this
is sad today
I saw this
when I saw this
today
I I actually scared poor Clarence
um Louis was on face he was just looking
at me but poor Clarence ran out of my
bedroom because I was scrolling down and
I saw I just read that first sentence
yeah and I was like you gotta be [__]
kidding me I screamed it at the top of
my lungs and Clarence went
I felt bad for him and I was like you
gotta be kidding me
this is insane she's insane the Miss
blue Miss Eliza blue
today I've decided to change my story as
a Survivor I have been abused no no no
no stop okay
I got all day my friend let's go let's
go merch please right there go ahead
if you
if you know this woman from Adam like
let's say that what there was no
controversy leading up to this if
somebody you barely knew just said that
you'd go oh ah see you're just full of
[__] then like you're an insane person
okay
I decided to change my story about how I
was almost murdered yeah no of course I
mean uh and then she says and then she
continues uh I have been abused the
third time I can't read it yes go ahead
I can't I have been abused the third
time on a massive digital scale okay get
ready she's invented okay this part yes
but no one now it's my turn
okay now I'm breaking this one huh
a massive digital scale guys we were
joking about this saying oh my God you
you've made fun of my Instagram video
you sex trafficked me she's doing it
literally now this is not a bit anymore
to her this is real okay merch go ahead
all right guys I want to explain to you
oh all right look what no no guys look
we look we have a lot of fun we better
get it out no we have a lot of fun here
on Revenge of the sis but I want to talk
to you about something that's no
laughing matter sure it's called image
based sexual abuse
ibsa
hold on hold on hold it hold on hold on
before you go any further Royce yes
Royce put on some p and put on some
public [__] okay
I got it I got it
hold on hold on oh my God Mercy get it
yeah
okay has anybody
important yet there you go there you go
merch can you please read that last one
again
[Music]
it's cold
[Laughter]
there's a horrible there's a horrible
Specter looming over our country
it's called image-based sexual abuse
every individual who knowingly profited
off of this content without my consent
has become my abuser in my story
Everyone's an abuser now you're all
anyone who click retweets my abuser you
all raped me for just a Bitcoin a day
you can you can stop image-based sexual
abuse in your community
[Laughter]
hi my name is Eliza blue and I'm on
Molly and I'm [__] gone and I suffer
from immigrant-based abuse hey do you
guys have any water I'm like really
thirsty next
ah go ahead Murphy you didn't fight
censorship you fought to exploit me nude
partially nude wait we got some news out
there we got any nudes back fresh out I
keep telling you [__] guys that there
are nudes out there and she's front
lashing to [__] before they come again
uh nude slash partially nude sexually
suggestive content without my consent if
you would have asked I would have
consented you believe that I we don't
have to I don't have to call you every
time I want to post a world star hip hop
okay
daunting that would be
Worldstar did ask you consented that's
why we were able to share it
I have to Now call Eliza blue whenever I
want to play a cooking with Jack video
yes yes and Thomas do I have to call
Thomas Murphy every time I want to play
one of his too
okay this is insane yeah I got him sword
and scale with 25 says cheers Jen cheers
to sword and skill who got [__] by
YouTube demonetize his channel it's
[__] up yeah we got to get him on
Rumble yes we do it's already on there
but we got to get him the hook the hook
up yeah talk to some guys okay uh we
were
uh if you asked I would have consented
you believe that I consented previously
so you decided to take my body and use
it for your game
so if she thinks that anyone that
retweets a thing she was already paid
for owes or something yeah owes her
money and you know what and it seems
like [__] hotep that'll give her half
the super chats you know what this is
verse you know what this is this is a
prostitute's mentality no it is this is
absolutely a whole mentality this is
this is how [__] strippers think or
hooker logic
I mean you know there was many names for
this for this phenomenon
it's a direct result of hopefully it's
ovulation 100 inflation we have a
saturation point on these homes so what
else did cardi bless say
[Laughter]
but she has blue in her name
doesn't matter okay fine uh merch I pull
uh they got the next one up here
uh so to prove that I'm not a Survivor
many made me a victim again you could
never say that I'm not a survivor of
exploitation now because you made me one
again
what what that's a Time Paradox she's
saying again like too many times no no
no no you can't say I'm not a survivor
of exploitation now because you just
exploited me but you used my old
exploitation which is arguably not
exploitation you've created a time
travel Paradox that's the Marty McFly
yeah I was about to say that stuff this
is the morning
a Terminator 2 Paradise uh you know for
real you can't how did Kyle Reese get
her pregnant
the first time like so he was born there
was never a problem with whatever just
[__] your mom Marty you didn't fight to
expose to be to be Contender he didn't
fight to expose government malfeasance
or Tech censorship you fought to post my
body without consent
you literally Eliza when you did the
World Star Hip-Hop video you filled out
a piece of paper
it was literally called a consent form
no that's what it's called I know I had
to sign one for the teddy heart thing I
can sense
for you to have from this interview
lifetime like it's yours it's not mine
I'm being interviewed for this you're
paying me a sum of money and you're also
getting a license for my show from that
episode set but I I it literally at the
top of that piece of paper uh it's like
the uh you know Affidavit of consent
okay
um
can you read this one
I'll pull it up does it it should be up
oh yeah this is where it's gonna get fun
I need brave men to stand up for me
right now please I'm begging you
I needed you
uh uh that's the first time over the
past three weeks I've asked anyone to
help me or stand up for me
Carlton pool no I said a straw a strong
man
hello beautiful woman with looks of
Bridget Nielsen my name is evgeny I am
here to save you get in shipping
container
laughs
no beautiful baby you get to see the
world you like Dubai you like yacht you
go on there yeah
ah so yeah my prediction is
uh she's gonna suicide bait next okay
it'll be a weak ass attempt
so it'll be like it'll be like an Eliza
blew her brains out kind of thing yeah
okay uh but she won't know women are
dude I really want to kill yourself
she's gonna do some uh across the street
uh you know across the road instead of
down the street
and uh she's gonna get a couple of
[__] more grifting like points off of
that everyone's gonna go look regardless
of whether or not this woman lied about
her past she's obviously mentally
unstable she's vulnerable yeah and all
of the blowback drove her to killing her
and it's going to be a real weak ass
thing and then she's gonna do this
suicide baiting of course and then the
next step is born again Christian watch
mark my word you think she's going full
full body going all in with that I'm
pushing all of my [__] chips on the
table I'm the fullborn again well this
this is this is just a blast from the
past a tweet from hers from three years
ago God please grab uh grant me with
enough influence to be attack like ye
God please grab me with enough
creativity to be attacked like he God
please let me shift the culture as many
times as he I'll use it to help kids and
survivors I promise
well welcome
I was so stupid we got some donations
here we have a real Tariq
Nasheed sent uh uh this picture and I'll
put it up on the screen for everybody
give me a second
um
there we go
and the real technology this man uh this
man sounds like white Jesse Lee Peterson
without brain damage another picture of
Elizabeth
uh hi I'm Elijah Blue I'm the face of
mesothelioma hi that that's from we're
going to see Danny Saint hi I'm Eliza
blue do you and your family members have
sexual uh sexual photos on the internet
that you agree to and signed off on you
could be entitled to compensation
jacket uh merge consented with peacock
to be labeled an alt-right comedian you
did consent you did consent you admit it
you admitted it
um so the other thing that occurred we
just bet
all of a sudden after losing 20
subscribers Tim Poole saw the light so
we're gonna uh dive head first into the
shallow end with this next story about
Eliza blue Chrissy Mayer and all the
stuff that's been gone over the past
week
what happened I thought the ESAT drama
was below you and the knee [__] boy
and uh we'll just uh we'll be as candid
as possible I'm sure we'll piss some
people off but we have this tweet from
Chrissy Mayer for those that aren't
familiar Chrissy Mayer is a comedian and
she hosts a podcast called simpcast and
she's been on the show I would like to
think that she hosts other shows other
than simcast so I think I think a couple
times right it's been a couple times
we've been on the show before and so
there's been some controversy related to
a guest we had recently Eliza blue shut
up there's been some this this this fake
like he like have you heard about this
he's like it's literally the only thing
anybody's talking about anytime you
tweet anything and some censorship
actions that she's been accused of
notably filing privacy requests against
people who talk about her past work and
so here we have the story from Chrissy
Mayer she says Eliza blue got four of my
YouTube videos removed for showing a
fair and balanced dock trailer which
featured three to five seconds of her
public at the time now removed World
Star Hip-Hop video must be nice to have
the power to rewrite history then
Gaslight Twitter and YouTube into
accepting it
now I'll say is that right
um you know I said previously I'm
uninterested in this and I'll kind of
you know I think this is this got to the
point where literally right before the
show I saw this tweet and I'm like okay
okay guys you got me all right like I'm
starting to see and learn more [__] off
[__] off you [__] beanie wearing
[__] off you [__] this was you knew
what was going on did he's acting like
this is the first time someone's been
Centered for the now now it's getting
serious yeah when Adonis Paul was
permanently suspended that wasn't
[__] serious right when people were
getting suspended off of Twitter that
wasn't [__] serious videos were being
taken down on Rumble and on Twitter but
that wasn't [__] serious now it's
serious don't pretend it's because of
what happened to Chrissy Marr which is
[__] up by the way but
be honest and it's because you were
hemorrhaging Subs you were looking like
a fat because you kept pretending there
was ethos drama you kept saying it's
ethos
even though you covered [__] what's
her face crying the other the twitch
thoughts crying the other day but
whatever man cover whatever you want
it's your show like you said but you're
being disingenuous and you're [__]
lying because you know what was going on
and everyone sees through it and same
thing with [__] with [__] boring
Jeremy too who's now firing everybody up
against Tim Poole now they're best
friends again they're apologizing and
they're tweeting and they're buddies and
we have to work together all of you are
[__] phonies every single one of you
I'm so sick of these [__] people man
I'm so sick of these [__] people yeah
it's all just one but I'm just tired but
now now you care by the way compared to
the other stuff that's happened this is
nothing
privacy complaints have been going on
for a while with it she was taking
people down for privacy complaints all
over the place and you knew it to him
and you didn't care you didn't care
because he was [__] playing grab ass
with your co-host
that's having me question what that what
what's going on if YouTube videos
getting pulled and we're hearing that a
bunch of people actually had YouTube
videos getting pulled and so this
clearly is an abuse of the system to a
degree that we've not seen for a while
now [__] off it's been going on for a
month and pretending that it just
started now is [__] [__] because
the truth of the matter is he's 100 he
got caught because people are like oh no
but you're champion of free speech you
you've he's gone after people for way
less than what Eliza's done way quicker
but the difference is she didn't [__] a
party with her co-host it used to be in
the early days of YouTube there were
attempts by political Rivals to to
falsely flag and get people's content
removed and now it seems like we're
seeing an uptick in this particularly
pertaining to Eliza Bloom the first
thing I'll say is as it pertains to the
issues related to me personally you know
look man
um I say it a million times I'm I'm an
arrogant [__] and so don't don't
come at me and yell at me I think I'm
gonna bend the knee and do anything for
you and I will tell everybody right off
the bat we had this person on the show
that I don't care too much about I don't
I don't follow her career I don't know
much about her I don't handle booking
we've had on the show two times oh now
he doesn't know he doesn't care he
doesn't follow he doesn't understand
he's been amazing and then she hung out
and jammed out with your boys by the way
damned by you boys by the way by the way
I love that I don't handle booking yeah
you're right because Tucker doesn't have
any input on the people he has on his
show his producers just throw random
people and he has to interview them you
really you have no [__] say of course
he has a say come on man this is such
[__] this is such [__] bull I'm
an arrogant [__] are you are you
really now I don't he goes from that's
the way I am I tell people that's the
way I am but also I want people to take
me super seriously
thicker pick a lane stupid it's still
all of a sudden like honestly if this is
an enraging video but it's nice to know
that even he was feeling enough pain
to be like all right I gotta do
something here it's not about bending
the knee you [__] phony piece of [__]
it's not about bending the knee yeah
it's not about bending the knee not
everything's a kick flip you yeah no you
know what it's for you know what it's
about Tim it's about being honest and by
being either you're protecting yourself
or you're protecting your co-host
because of whatever stuff you're worried
about and that's what you were doing you
now it's now he's turning into the this
is basically when Biden does this by the
way and Biden does what he just did he's
Mr like that's not you're the president
buck stops at you hey it's not called
Cassandra cast IRL it's called Kim cat
Tim cast so you would assume that you
have a say in who's coming in and you do
a little research or what is it really
just a grab bag you don't know who's
showing up
see that's the thing it's he lies
erotic control freak just comes in and
wings It Like Us [__] out of here
[__] in pool salty engineer ten
dollars yeah
no no but enough man enough he you are
an arrogant [__] you're 100 an arrogant
[__] and you know what we're kind of
arrogant [__] if we're being honest of
course Reagan [__] but you know what
I'm salt of the earth
yeah merch is great guy all of us Long
Island people assaulted the Earth yeah
we're [__] trash but we're also not
the ones thinking that we're getting
that we we need did you saw his reply to
quartering apology accepted we need to
work together these [__] people
really think they've changed anything or
are doing anything other than sucking
each other's own dicks and Mr [__]
Tim pool Mr journalists need to keep
themselves out of the story Dives beanie
first into every story to make himself
the [__] center of attention and then
he goes on Twitter and he wants to be
serious journalist guy is going to
travel around in his van with a [__]
toilet in it and [__] crew soft
Mysteries like he's some sort of
effeminate half cheeky Scooby-Doo and
and nobody [__] cares because he
didn't go on the [__] dick it's
living in a van it's [__] sucks he's
in his [__] compound where Cassandra
just brings him guests on a [__]
platter and he's admitting he admitted
that he does no [__] background work
so what are you phoning it in now Tim
see that's my point at least take
accountability for the people that you
talk to that you platform because you're
like people come at me because they want
to come on my show fine and that's fine
people asked us to be on the show too
obviously not as much as you your show's
much bigger but also don't [__] sit
there if we have somebody on the show
like like if we had I don't know if we
had Harrison Smith on this show
yesterday right and then two days later
it's found out that he's like wanted for
a bank robbery we would have to talk
about it we wouldn't go like oh I don't
handle the booking Frozen books to
people on the show we have no idea who's
coming on you know yeah I was thrown off
so I thought the whole thing I had no
idea he's just so phony bro
yeah they're calling him Scooby
yeah in his [__] Mystery Machine
where are you
frozen is that you
uh this is a Ian's apology or not
apology explanation excuse me he does
these people don't apologize that would
have that would mean they'd have
humility
drama because drama will find you if you
keep doing what you love and and are
public about it I think it's inevitable
you don't have to create it or find it
it will just find you and yeah like a
[__] foot and you're groin
this one moment it's not there the next
moment it's there yeah seriously
there's a video going around of me and
Eliza rolling around on the couch
snuggling and hanging out with Adam
Crigler and nishra almond and uh
partying all night that was fun so
uh Eliza what's happening I don't like
talking about people when they're not
around Adam Nisha love you guys
so I'll try and explain the situation
but I'm not gonna like talk about people
I'll like to talk directly to you if
you're listening it's a weird social
media is weird because like I don't need
yeah cool get to it we'll need to talk
about censorship if it happens unjustly
um and it's a sacrifice because it does
distract me from what I'm working on and
doing but I want to mention this because
Brittany Venti Brittany you uh I watched
a video that you were explaining what
happened you got your Twitter account
banned and apparently it was because you
you posted a link to him I loved I love
by the way I love that this is a day ago
I love that that this pretty event thing
has been going on for more than a month
and now all of them notice pool and and
[__] and and this [__] [__] are
are all are all now all of a sudden
going like I just heard about this yeah
I just oh I just found out I just
checked my email for the first time in a
month right right it's just not
correlated with that video of you
getting a [__] over the pants foot
job like you're in [__] High School
playing truth or dare
video on YouTube that was public and hey
Eliza picked there I dare you to shut
the [__] up forever
I went through your video and looked up
some data to find out exactly what's
happening or if you pick truth hey true
have you ever shut the [__] up
I got some screenshots I want to pull up
publicly still like you know where does
the line blend
feelings from what I know right now I
don't have all the data wow you're
boring dude it doesn't have the data oh
all of these people got to change the
circle are so more back
hey is there any copium on that [__]
periodic table behind him
because all these guys now all of a
sudden they care now all of a sudden
this [__] matters when accounts are
getting [__] lost and people are
losing their YouTube channels and losing
their [__] and getting privacy
complaints and being threatened and
getting nobody now you care which you
know what you know I would have [__]
solved this entire scenario right at the
very beginning at the very very very
beginning you know I would have solved
this all you had to do Tim was go like
hey man look we've had a lot of people
on the show a couple times and if he's
really censoring people that's really
[__] up and I'm against that
all of this would have gone away that's
it all you had to do was for one second
just be like man that really sucks
you know I don't I don't want people to
lose it you know I'm a big proponent of
people not losing their accounts and
people that I've only losing their
accounts and I don't want that to happen
you know I go after the government and I
I the problem is is that Eliza blue was
was his [__] video of thought right
that that that weasels her way into the
right wing Community right
like like that's that that's that's what
you know what I mean
well I've been as we've always said that
the problem with the you know
right-wingers particularly the the fans
and viewers of these kinds of shows in
this kind of community they're also
eager to just be liked that and we've
seen it they're all so eager to be liked
and eager to be like not called
homophobic yeah racist and if you're
just a chick or a token black guy or a
gay guy they're just so quick to be like
we're like we always said like d-list
celebs you know like all of a sudden
[__] I'm supposed to believe Kevin
Sorbo is [__] cool stop it yeah and
sorba was never cool you know what I
mean like stop it now Tim is pretending
he's gonna stop Tim cast and quartering
is saying things like uh don't leave Bud
we need you here you [__] [__] all of
you are grifting [__] and your carnies
and it's funny because merch and I get
made funner for liking wrestling what
you guys like is even [__] gayer
because at least merch and I know what
we're watching is fake
yeah I could see [__] Moxley blading
on them yeah
exactly and honestly I watch wrestling
sometimes because of those moments yeah
I watch it more for that like when
you're a kid you watch wrestling and go
wow cool but you're supposed to get to
an age or you still enjoy it but you're
like maybe that's because we still enjoy
wrestling and we love picking things
apart all the time that we're so good at
picking off all these works on the
internet because they're just copying
pro wrestling and it's like something
it's just we've watched enough bad
promos and we've watched enough people
blade on the hard camera and just slicy
slicy slice I mean it's like we've seen
people slip and botch and at this point
it's like you've seen it all we look for
that [__] it's more fun but at least the
thing we watch we know is fake and you
[__] marks are giving all and I'm not
also not sending [__] five dollar
super chats to [__] Chris Jericho
every five minutes
good point
oh Judas is cool you know yeah you know
I really liked you it's really a good
song is it [__] shut up uh we got
another donation of 20 from Sage [__]
detective merch is on Eliza's case
according to Jack GPT I sent I sent it
both places this time apparently there
is a Noir script where famous internet
personality merged from nightwave Radio
is a 1940s detective taking down taking
on a con woman known as Eliza blue
titled night wave detective do you want
to do it it's pretty funny I just
skimmed it you should have it again oh
he should send me another one yeah you
should have it in your DMs and it's a
good one okay so here let me hold on
before you start because it is merch
Noir so that means that we need the
Noir music okay
[Music]
there you go
all right I'll I'll set the stage okay
okay all right so I'm gonna read it
again
[Music]
uh scene
Mercer's office a dimly lit room with a
desk a typewriter and a file cabinet
Mercy sitting at his desk smoking a
cigarette and staring at a picture of a
beautiful woman
they call me Marsh the night wave
detective and I've seen it all in this
city The Good the Bad and the Ugly on
this case this one's different a knock
on the door interrupts Marcia's thoughts
come in
a woman enters wearing a fur coat and a
wide brimmed hat she introduces herself
as Eliza blue Mr
Always by the way was there just one
scene in all of the Noir movies yeah was
that the only thing movies was the hutch
because that's like the Trope right so
he's the hot chick coming in she had
arms for days that's what I mean it's
every single day every stereotype I'm
like do you guys ever leave the office
or you just have hot chicks coming and
going all right I got Mr Mash I need
your help
what makes you think I can help you miss
blue
takes off her hat I've been fright Mr
mesh I need you to clear my name I think
your wig came off with that halfway huh
now you look like a bald Mexican man
sorry you're improving
If This Were The Sopranos
but it's not uh Vince McMahon were
around
[Music]
by who
a dangerous man with a lot of power and
influence I can't go to the police
they're always they're in on it but I
know you're different Mr Bush I've heard
about your reputation
you gotta go to here miss blue I'll take
your case but I want the truth no lies
no deceit
thank you Mr merch I'll tell you
everything
everything cuts to version Eliza blue
working together uh to uncover the truth
visiting crime scenes interviewing
Witnesses and Gathering evidence but as
they get closer to the truth they
realize that the danger is greater than
they initially thought and that Eliza
blue may not be as innocent as she
claims to be
oh okay by the way I love how Chachi BT
gets lazy and I was like I don't know
Montage in there it's just like a human
writer yes I don't know it just sling
some [__] together they got a magnifying
glass and a chalk outline and an empty
bottle of Jameson on the desk exactly
and a cigarette that's burning in the in
the in the ashtray
um the deeper on drugs the more I
realized this case was bigger than just
a simple frame up there were forces at
play that I couldn't even begin to
comprehend but one thing wasn't clear
Miss blue was hiding something the
climax of the story see Smurfs
confronting Eliza blue who's finally
confessed as to being a con artist who
has used her charms to manipulate people
for her own game
Hershey's face with a difficult decision
whether to turn on her turn her in or
let her go in the end he decides to turn
her in but not before giving her a
chance to make amends for her actions
they say that in this city Justice is
blind but sometimes he's a little help
from people like me to make sure the
right thing is done the scene ends with
ends with a shot of Mer sitting at his
desk looking out the window while Eliza
blue is shown being taken away by the
police the camera Zooms in on Mercer's
face and he takes a drag of his
cigarette and mutter says himself
another case solved another chapter in
the life of the night wave Detective
today's episode of night wave detective
was brought to you by Winston cigarettes
nine out of 10 doctors recommend Winston
cigarettes if you're pregnant that's
right that was amazing thank you Sage
[__] Chet GPT is the [__] winner
I'm also afraid it's going to replace us
Marsh
um well why was Eliza being arrested why
would she'd be getting taken away by
police outside of my office is what I
would do I'd be that's that's your
problem with the story yeah
God every detective it's the same it
really is a stupid thing it really is
just the hot chick comes into a guy
smoking in an office it really is to
help and it's oh she's always ends up
being the bad guy how many of those
movies did they make it you know it's
not even because you know chapter pulls
just from everything so it's not even
the movies but how many parodies of it
have there been there too right so
that's what I'm saying like because the
parodies of the parody exactly exactly
what was the original there had to be
one original time that that scene was
the thing you're being called the new
Humphrey Bogart in the chat I like it I
actually really like that um